[موسيقى]
رغم تخوف الخيال العلمي من تمردها على
اسيادها ابداع الانسان في ابتكار اشكال
مختلفه من الروبوتات لتحميل عنه اعبائه
وتنجزها باقل وقت ومجهود وبغض النظر كيف
ينظر اليها كصديقه الوفيه او خادمه مطيعه
فهي اليوم جزء من حلم كبير في العصر
الرقمي فما القصه
يعود اصل كلمه روبوت الى الكلمه تشيكيه
روبوته التي تعني العمل الجبري او العبد
وتم استخدامه لاول مره منذ 100 عام
في مسرحيه لكار الكابتش قدم فيها رجالا
الميكانيكيين يعملون في مصنع لكنهم في
النهايه تمرد على اسيادهم
ثم
ظهر هذا الكائن المستقبلي كبطل في العديد
من القصص والاعمال السينمائيه وانقسم دوره
بين الخير المطيع والشرير المتمرد لكن من
وجهه نظر العلم الذي بحث طويلا عن تسخير
التكنولوجيا لخدمته في الروبوتات ليست
الاجهزه متعدده الوظائف قابله للبرمجه بما
يتناسب معها مهامها ومن هنا بدات محاولات
اختراع المساعد الالي
فكانت اولى هابي نحو ثلاثه الاف عام قبل
الميلاد حيث استخدمت في الساعه المائيه
المصريه تماثيل بشريه لقرع اجراس الساعه
كذلك اخترع ارخميدس في عام 400 قبل
الميلاد حمامه خشبيه يمكنها الطيران ثم تم
بناء التماثيل الهيدروليكيه في مصر خلال
القرن الثاني قبل الميلاد وكانت لديها
انذاك القدره على التحدث بالاماءات كما
استخدمت للتنبؤات
في القرن الاولي بعد الميلاد
صنع باترون يوسف تتحرك مثل الانسان ثلاثه
محاوله جيوفاني ترياني ابتكار روبوتا خشبي
يجلب الخبز اليوميه للامبراطور من المتجر
في عام
وصلت الاختراعات الروبوتيه توليد النسبيه
في القرنين 18 وال 19
كما دخلت الروبوتات في الصناعه باوروبا
ففي عام 1804 كشف الفرنسي جوزيف ماري
جاكار عن منوال النسيج وكان هذا الروبوت
الذي عرف لاحقا باسم جوكر
يرفع الخيوط ويحركها وكان سببا في اتمته
صناعه النسيج
في القرن العشرين حدثت الثورات الاكبر في
عالم الروبوتات ففي اوائل الخمسينيات من
القرن الماضي اخترع جورج سي دي فول روبوت
يونيت القابله لاعاده البرمجه لكنه لم
يلقى رواجا تجاريا حتى جاء يوسف انجل برجر
وعدله بما يتماشى مع الصناعه ونجح بتسويقه
حتى اصبح يوصف بانه ابو الروبوتات
بمثابه ذراع اليه بقابض قابل للدوران
يمكنها من الحركه لاعلى واسفل وحمل
الاشياء الثقيله لكنها عانت من كبار حجمها
واعتمادها على المواد الهيدروليكيه
القابله للتسرب مع حد من استخدامها الى ان
جاء فيكتور شايمان بنموذج ذراع ستامبورد
الذي كان صغيرا ويعمل بالكهرباء ليعلن
بدايه عصر الروبوتات الصناعيه في عام
1972 انتج باحث معهد ستانفورد للابحاث اول
روبوت يستخدم الذكاء الاصطناعيه وهو شيكي
الذي كان قادرا على التنقل ودفع صندوق على
طول الارض
ومراقبه العالم من حوله من خلال
المستشعرات والكاميرات
تنوعت لاحقا الابتكارات في عالم الروبوتات
ولم تعد فقط في الصناعه ومن الامثله على
ذلك ابتكار رومبا الذي يمكنه كنسو غرفه
بالكامل وكان اول روبوت وظيفيا يحققون
نجاحا حقيقيا مع الجمهور حيث بلعب اكثر من
15 مليون حتى بدايه الالفيه وتحقيقا لرغبه
العلماء في جعل الروبوتات اكثر تفاعلا تم
انتاج روبوت
وهو راس الالي لوجه معبر مصمم لاثاره
المشاعر والتفاعل معها اليوم اصبحت
امكانيه التواصل مع الروبوتات متاحه من
خلال هاتفك الذكي واصبح المساعد الالي
تسال من روتين الحياه اليوميه لكثير من
الاشخاص مع امثله لا حسر لها على غزو
الروبوتات لعالم البشر
[موسيقى]